Scotland's longest serving fast Minister
walking into a week of final acts this
her last speech in London her successor
set to be announced in seven days time
my own party is in the midst of how will
I describe it as somewhat fractious
leadership election a leadership
election she so far said little about
her party now in freefall Nicholas
sturgeon today issuing some gentle
warnings for those wanting to Walk In
Her Shoes I'm not suggesting that this
is not a difficult process and at times
it has been a less than edifying process
and what I'd say to all of those
standing to succeed me as Leaders
remember that I am standing down from a
party that hasn't lost an election in
Scotland since 2010 I think after so
long in government this is a moment for
refresh renewal change but let's not
throw the baby out with the bath water
we have the trust of the people of
Scotland and we've got to make sure we
retain that trust retaining trust right
now proven difficult a party suffering
dwindling membership and a police probe
into its finances the fast Minister
insists this played no part in her
resignation but her stepping down an
electoral gamble there's a downside risk
put it that way and you must see that of
course but there would be a downside
risk of me staying on Beyond
the point at which I thought I was the
right person personally and politically
I actually think in standing down now
rather than six months or a year from
now I'm giving my party the ability to
go through this process come out of it
stronger and be fighting fit for the
general election when it comes
but worries recent storms might be
dampening their prospects losing a
Council seat here in sterling in recent
days people here uncertain about the
party's future if the SNP wants to carry
on in terms of their following that's
going to be jeopardized by the
inexperience of of all of the candidates
not one of them worth the job I don't
think it will never be the same no since
then
depends what they do now
a week
did recovery though far from guaranteed
Beth Rigby Sky News